the jurgen experience
i was so enthusiastic about this
and and and i said people say don't talk
about it but i said no i'm so ex i'm not
here to take the people's money
you know the money the money that comes
in from the government i want to put it
to to programs and i want to make make
this
make this uh
this government administ this governor's
administration as powerful as it can
possibly be and
i want to
you know i it's about holding on to that
power to i've only planned to run for
to run for one term because i'm not here
at all i'm not here to be a i want to be
with the people the mana is with the
people we have the power i want to be
with the people
i i'm only planning on going in for for
one term can i ask you this though what
if you don't accomplish everything you
want to get done in one term what if
it's more difficult to get through the
maze of bureaucracy
i'm here to work with
i i want a strong lieutenant governor i
i have the lieutenant governors that i
see that are coming in i want to work
with well with everybody and endorse who
i have to if the people need me and they
say bj let's do it we need you one more
time of course i'm going to come and
stand up for the people you know and
that's why i have no problem even doing
this in the first place i would have
never had the life that i had if the
people of hawaii didn't support me the
way they did i would have never got to
this success and and all of these things
i didn't win every fight i would come
home with my face be beaten and battered
and and the people from hawaii the
people of hawaii would say
hey you gotta fight again bj you can do
it you're our hero come on let's show em
you can show all the kids show everybody
we can don't mess with hawaiians you
know we can do this and they've always
stood behind me and i got no problem
doing this for them and it's for our
children and for everybody so
i'm just you know i'm in and they're
going to keep coming after me they're
going to keep throwing whatever they can
at me and let's go let's go bj you got
to get together with jerry uh with um
jesse ventura
i will i yes i need i need to talk to i
was just i had him in mind jesse the
body and hawaii's got so many different
problems with our housing problem our
energy problems now everything with the
gas and i really want to invite elon
musk to come over and and see if he
could help us with hawaii because it's
it's a landlocked state and
you know everything comes in off the
boat and you got everybody talking about
the jones act do you know what the jones
act is no
that's an act that makes all
international boats go to california
first before they come to hawaii they
can't just come to hawaii this was made
back when hawaii was a territory so
all kinds of different things that a lot
of people different people talk about
you know so inefficient the the um
you know hawaii is the most unionized
state but
our families all work in those unions
we're all together so we all have to
figure out how to
uh update all of these different things
and make them work properly do we just
bring the boats from in do we do we
build our docks bigger so they can take
international boats but just have our
unions be the ones to take to take all
the stuff off their boats so our unions
still you know control the docks and not
other people not international people
controlling our docks because of course
we want our people from home those are
our cousins those are our family right
you know so what whatever you know you
hear all kinds of different stuff
from you know the big things in hawaii
right now
the housing the rising cost of living
you know the education
and
and the this the rising cost of living
is is what's killing everybody right now
and and and we we have no
self-sustainability
you know you see you know how big the
big island is i believe we could do the
right thing and you know from from
wailuku river to waipio valley that's 50
miles of water and farmland and and
they're talking about growing 100
million trees for the climate i'm saying
every tree better have fruit on it then
every tree better have food on it you
know
we're stuck
dependent on a boat coming in and out
and even more we have to protect our
waters you know all the water is
um held in perpetuity to the people of
hawaii but we almost need to go one step
further and
and make it a national treasure i didn't
say a federal treasure i said the
national treasure to the people where
you can't just start diverting waters
and doing all these things and i mean
you take half the water from a stream
coming down you kill half the life that
was around in that stream
you know and these are all
things that i've seen growing up
and that we have to think about our
sustainability and sustainability right
sustain as you're staying in the same
place we need to thrive we need to move
forward the airplanes come in full
they drop everything off and they go
back empty
why
why why does that happen it doesn't make
any sense how much change would have to
be done for hawaii to be completely
self-sustainable like like what kind of
industries would you have to put there
well you never have to get anything off
of a boat is that even possible well i
don't know what we would have to figure
out what we're going to do with
petroleum but that's that's why i want
to talk to people like
like elon you know that's why i want to
people who who know
different things you got a lot of sun
but i think solar we got a lot of sun we
got a lot of sun i think solar in its
current form um
is great but i don't think it's really
capable of running a whole city yet you
know
we gotta
i don't i don't know what we have out
there you know we have to
figure out i mean the gas is expensive
the gas is expensive in hilo yeah gas
expensive everywhere
it's uh it's weird
i've never been able to understand that
right is that did the oil disappear
overnight where did it go where did it
all go you know somebody tried to
explain it to me and i glazed over i was
like i can't pay attention to this
whenever we go to any other like there's
a lot of like speaking meetings right
and i think hey this is some real mixed
martial arts this stuff because not only
do you have to know what what you got to
do when you get in well there's a lot of
black and white stuff and that's like
freedoms or like basic stuff and then
there's state budgets you know what i
mean it's great yeah yeah grey areas you
know that's that's where that's where
you've got to have a lot of people
helping you out right you know what i
mean